hey guys Pete here this will be my mr.
robot season 2 episode 5 recap and there
will be spoilers with everything that
has happened up to this point in season
2 this episode started off a little slow
but by the end it was a full-blown crazy
ride so let's jump right into it and the
opening scene we see Elliott is back at
the terminal and Rey's office it's got
like this cool music in the background
and we see him marking jumping back and
forth between different windows I didn't
really even notice the fact that it was
dark in the room until Lone Star comes
over and the lights go up Elliott
explains to us what he's doing and the
steps necessary to take control of the
FBI's phones this plan sounds solid and
we hear that everything is ready to go
in his chat with Darlene basically they
are planning on placing a cell signal
network extender at Ecore that Elliott
can use to intercept all their traffic
he describes it as his own personal cell
tower but it's really a small device
that looks like a router and you know
people have them in their homes if they
have dark spots and things like that and
they can't get a signal on the fake IRC
page that the show put up was the last
episode I think it was you can now find
an update data conversation between
Elliott and Darlene that explains it in
better detail than they do on the show
he finishes writing the malware so all
they need to do is get the device into
the building he then tells Lone Star
that he that he needs to see the old IT
guy in order to finish the site
migration for Rae he tells him he will
have to talk to Ray about it and that
ends the scene we find DOM and Steel
mountain and she gets a look at where
they found the Raspberry Pi that Elliott
planted in season 1 it's a quick scene
but we also find out that they're
getting ready to reopen the facility
under a different name
angela comes into her apartment to find
darlene inside working on her laptop we
see Darlene is running a file from a
flash drive and that she finishes up
right as Angela realizes she's there
Angela asked what she's doing there and
Darlene explains that she needs Angela's
help Angela isn't on board with the idea
she says she hasn't heard anything from
her for five weeks and now she shows up
out of the blue asking for help
darn Darlene tells are fine and says she
hopes for Angela's and Elliott's sake no
one else knows about the CD that Angela
infected allsafe with joanna shows up at
a restaurant to meet with the parking
lot attendant he's basically tripped out
thinking that he's being watched and
says he can't keep lying to the FBI
Joanna thanks him for telling her what
going on and promises that everything
will be okay Annie Court DOM is talking
to an FBI agent that we haven't met yet
and we find out that they're going to
China something that stands out here is
that Dom says she hates coming to e
Court because the security is so relaxed
the FBI agent also tells her about a
dream she had with the guy wearing a
surgical mask Dom says that she really
doesn't dream because I'd never
interested her which i think is pretty
hilarious
Darlene visits Ellie at their mom's
house and tells him that she reached out
to Angela which pisses him off she says
they need her to plant the femtocell at
Ecore and he says that using Angela
isn't an option mr. robot sides with
Darlene but in the end Elliot tells her
to figure something else out and make it
happen
Dom arrives in China and we get a sort
of unexplainable shot of two men wearing
dark army masks going up the escalator
she's going down
it's weird since I can't imagine any
airport anywhere in the world being okay
with people walking around with masks
that cover their entire faces but either
way we forget about this right away when
we find out that white rose as a male is
the person who greets them which means
he holds a high position in the Chinese
government I mentioned in my last video
that it seemed important that she talked
to price with her male voice and now I
guess we can connect the dots price
doesn't seem to know her as the white
rose persona and it isn't necessary and
he's not necessarily in cahoots with the
leader of the dark army this wasn't a
hundred percent clear either way but I
think there's evidence that their
relationship is unrelated to the actual
hack the Chinese and the FBI sit down to
talk about the destruction of the data
backups and we get this awesome exchange
when Dom asked about the dark army BD
Wong gives her this classic are you
serious look and then politely explains
that they will give the FBI all the
information that they have on the dark
army in her apartment Johanna gets a
really expensive looking baby rattle in
the mail the envelope is plain and it
doesn't seem to have anything else in it
that she can use to figure out who sent
it or you know where Tyrell is basically
I leave this talking to Ray at the
basketball court explaining he can't
finish his work without meeting with
Artie who is the old site sysadmin
we get a hot Carlos sighting and she's
burning something in her red wagon Ray's
dog Maxine isn't looking too good but he
changes the subject and tells Elliot he
will send our
over to the office to help him out if he
says he really needs to see him Johanna
is singing to the baby and mr.
Southerland comes in he tells her he
couldn't find out anything more about
who sent the rattle after tracking it
back to the post office he says you know
it was a local post office but it must
have been you know dropped off at one of
the mail collection sites she asked him
if he took care of the parking lot
attendant and when he said he did she
asked him for details about his death we
get a complete report and find out Joana
wanted him to use a drug to paralyze
cream first instead of killing him right
away
she explains to Sutherland that she
wanted to give him time to process why
he was dying and the process would give
him answers her justification is that
otherwise they would just be ruthless
murderers her character moves up a
couple notches on the creepiness scale
as she looks completely unfazed hearing
about the details of the death and the
next scene we find Angela meeting up
with her shady-ass ex-boyfriend Ali
remember he's the one who originally put
the CD containing the malware in his
laptop and that's what gave Cisco the
leverage to have Angela planner at all
say they have an awkward conversation
where he seems to still have a thing for
Angela and she seems like she's made a
clean break and really couldn't care
less part of the way through she sees
him move his cellphone and realizes that
he's actually recording the conversation
she freaks out and eventually he admits
that that he's been pulled in by the FBI
and he's been interviewed three times he
says he didn't mention her but he did
work with the sketch artist so that they
could have a drawing of Cisco now back
in China Dom was looking at a place at
the party of white roses house after a
couple glasses of champagne she goes
searching for the bathroom and ends up
in a room full of clocks White Rose
finds her there and Dom gets some
insight into her obsession with time
what Rose is asking about her past and
specifically how she became an FBI agent
and that leads to one of the best quotes
of the episode her answer is I am
disgusted by the selfish brutality of
the world but at the same time I am
utterly fascinated by it the FBI is the
perfect place for that kind of
contradiction they moved to white roses
office to take in some art and the
office itself is pretty freakin opulent
when pressed on tells the story of being
in her last semester of law school and
having her significant other proposed on
one knee at a restaurant it's a little
bit hard to tell if she's just
uncomfortable talking
about it but she's definitely vague in
her description of the relationship they
some people have pointed out that you
never freely hear her say like hey he
got down on his knee or she got down on
his knee so on the story ends with Dom
excusing herself mid proposal to go to
the bathroom
leaving out the back door and then
eventually choosing to work in the FBI
instead not sure if there's anything
behind that or if it's just another
example I thought awkward Dom is doing
anything other than her job but we do
find out that white roses official title
is China's Minister of State Security
let me get this weird scene where White
Rose takes Dom into her bedroom and
shows her a bunch of dresses she doesn't
answer when Dom asked whose room it is
and then tells her that the dresses
belong to her sister that's strange
because it's a story that Dom can easily
fact check I guess you would say and
she'll definitely find out it's a lie
what right Rose asked if she ever
wondered what it would be like if the
5/9 hack didn't happen and then talks
about alternate realities it's odd and
Dom doesn't really know how to react
when you know white rose starts to get
emotional right on time of course the
clocks start to chime as midnight
strikes and that gives White Rose the
out and the chance to say goodbye to her
what's the scene a few times and I still
don't know what to make of it why Perez
is trying to get a read on Dom that part
is obvious but I don't understand why
white rose shows her the dresses and
mentions the sister that doesn't exist
I'm sure it's been part of a bigger plan
but I can't really see how it's gonna
play out at this point Angela comes to
see Elliot to take his temperature about
what's going on her meeting with Olli
has but you know made her more
cooperative to try to get rid of any
evidence that might implicate them but
she says she wants to hear from Elliot
himself you know that he'll be able to
pull it off after explaining that she's
ready to do it they catch up a bit and
led explains why he's been staying away
he tells her about remembering the train
platform in season 1
you know when they after they found him
in the cemetery and how she told him to
take care of himself he says he wanted
to make him go away
you know mr. robot but that he could see
his dead father standing behind her
right now this is a good reminder for us
of how off the rails Elliot was at the
end of last season and how wrapped up
Darlene and Angela were
you know in the middle of it when it all
went down something that is off about
this scene for me is Elliot's mom in the
other room I'm not on board with the
institution theory about season two that
it's so popular right now I mean I know
there's some definite evidence that that
there's something going on but I find it
odd that you know when people visit
Elliot at his mom's house they talk so
openly what they're sitting right there
you know at the same time when Darlene
was there earlier she asked where she is
and refers to her as the she-devil which
could be anyone I guess but I mean it
seems like she's talking about their
mother I don't know like I said I don't
want to go down a rabbit hole because I
think any prison or mental institution
references that sort of stand out in
this season it just seems more
believable to me that they're about the
fact of you know about the prison that
you know Elliot has inside of his own
mind but why wouldn't they at least be
whispering if she's sitting right there
in the other room we find out Darlene
and her eff society cohorts are still
squatting in Madame executioners
apartment they're getting ready to put
their plan into action for the federal
bailout in DC and Darlene tells one of
the guys she can't go so that he'll have
to be the lead of the DC op we also see
that they have this giant drone which
looks pretty badass
RT drops by to help Elliot get into the
incorrect encrypted database Elliot is
staring at his beat-up face and we can
see that he really does have a rat tail
haircut
he opens notepad so you can ask Artie
about why he quit working on the site
and that and he ends up giving Elliot
the address so he can see it for himself
mr. robot chimes in as the voice of
reason to tell Elliot he doesn't know
when to stop and you know in a way he is
right like doing the migration was the
means to the end you know he wanted to
get on a terminal but Elliot you know he
obviously decides to go against Ray's
one and only rule which was not go
looking around where he doesn't need to
he talks briefly about if-then moments
with logic bones and he isn't sure if
Ray's if then if this is raised if then
moment or his own he looks at the site
and sees that beyond the normal dark net
market you know drugs for sale there's
human trafficking trafficking going on
weapons for sale and hitman for hire
this obviously gives Elliot a moral
dilemma so he goes home and argues with
mr. robot about it mr. robot wants him
to ignore in
because this means Rey is I mean if he's
into this stuff then he's not someone
you want to tangle with you know you
could compare them to the you know the
child porn guy in the beginning of the
first season that guy's not gonna do
anything
Rey obviously it's a different kind of
beasts Elliott can't get the images that
he saw from the website out of his head
though and he decides that he needs to
take down Rey in his black market of
evil it's an interesting you know
conversation that he has when this robot
and sort of with himself about the fact
that you know Rey was actually
protecting and you know it's just I
think in the end it just shows that all
that character build up for Rey was just
a you know showcase what a manipulator
he was
we'll have to see though I'm not sure
joanna is sitting watching the music box
like it's a TV when the mysterious phone
that came with it starts to ring she
answers and even though no one speaks we
hear a siren on the line that we
realized is right outside of her house
as well like she hears it in the phone
first and then realizes it's right
outside at the same time she runs out to
see if she can catch a glimpse of
tyrella whoever's on the phone but all
we see is an ambulance driving away
before the singing cuts to another one
it's tyro there and just wanted to get a
look at his wife you know surely there's
no way that he can just pop in and see
her inside the house right I mean
they're watching it but we'll just have
to wait and see on this one too I mean
they're they're just cliffhanger in us
here angels on the way to see Darlene
and takes a complicated route that
involves changing cabs jumping on the
you know subway all this to make sure
she isn't split isn't followed Darlene
meets her at the door
and brings her inside where we can see
that FF Society reunion with Mowgli and
Trenton on the premises r.i.p romero but
besides that the gang's all back
together we go back to china just in
time for all hell to break loose Dom
says she thinks she needs more caffeine
to survive the day and as she walks over
to this buffet table thing
two gunmen come in and start shooting
everyone Dom manages to duck behind the
serving area and gets a leg shot in on
one of the shooters as they cleared the
corner he tries to shoot back but it
eventually just ends up shooting himself
in the head and committing suicide
rather than allow
self to be captured only all the agents
we saw other than Dom are dead and the
shooter is still moving around looking
ready to go so I'm not really sure why
it was necessary for him to commit
suicide right there I mean it was cool
to show how dedicated they were to the
cause or whatever but I'm you know it
seemed like a little bit premature Don
slides back as the other shooter you
know starts to approach and we hear the
ringing in her ears and then the scene
just ends in a tone turns out to be a
complete cliffhanger we cut straight to
Eliot in bed who wakes up to find out
that he has visitors two giant guys rip
him out of his bed and drag him outside
he's greeted by Lone Star who throws
Artie's rat tail on the ground and we
noticed that it's not just the hair but
there's still a good amount of skin
connected to it then ray gets out of the
car and tells them that he told him not
to look from there his thugs start
beating Elliot down and the episode
comes to a close
Elliot did take a shot at reasoning with
Ray but he didn't hear it at all he just
you know his plan was already in motion
so like I said it started off slow but
we went straight into some high
intensity cliffhanger mode at the end
this was not my favorite episode of the
season so far but there's definitely a
lot of things in motion now so it's set
up you know it set up some of these
stories that have to come to an end at
some point we see in the preview for
episode 6 that Elliot looks like he's in
the hospital but then someone rolls in
and grabs him there too so I don't know
it doesn't really appear that he's free
or at least if he is right now he's not
gonna stay free I'm not sure if this is
because he was screaming when they took
him out of his his room which would make
a lot of sense since he looked at his
mother and even if she didn't hear it a
neighbor might have heard it and like
ray and his buddies just beat him down
and left him there or whatever
I don't really know on the other hand if
no one heard him screaming it that would
be a pretty big plot hole I think at
this point so we'd have to you know it
may lead to some sort of mental health
twist but I'm waiting until the next
episode to see how that plays out
because like I said it does look like
he's actually in a hospital but they're
coming back to take him again or
whatever so Angela's back in the fold
White Rose is a high-ranking Chinese
official f societies all in one place
and back together working together Rey
is on the dark side Elliot is in over
his head
Tyrell could possibly be nearby I think
it's likely he's nearby and Dom's life
is in
immediate danger it's a lot to think
about before the next episode and
there's no clear answers as to what's
going to come next in the trailer for
the next episode we didn't get any
Phillip price in this episode but
besides that all the major storylines
took a step ahead it was pretty clear at
the end of the last episode that there
was more to Rey than meets the eye and
now I don't see how Elliott will be able
to coexist with him from here on out if
we want to get into wild speculation I
would say the tyrell could potentially
be involved with how Elliott gets out
from under raid but that's really
because I don't see Elliott killing him
himself and I can't imagine how any of
the other characters would be useful to
him here I mean Rey's got raised a
serious dude and you know it's not just
gonna be a hacking situation the game
between DOM and whiterose is a little
bit hard to figure out I think it's safe
to say White Rose has a well-thought-out
plan and reasons for showing Dom the
secret identity more or less but I have
to say that the Johanna story has been
sort of annoying the whole thing with
mr. Sutherland in the parking lot
attendant it's just been hard to you
know see what the significance of all
that stuff is like I get the idea that
she has a good reason for him to be
quiet about Elliot being there but not
sure why the FBI would be putting so
much heat on the attendant in the first
place and why it's so crucial to her
personally and like I said in the last
video like who is mr. feather in anyways
like where where is his allegiance and
why is he just willing to go out and
kill people for it the story it just
seems drawn out and hopefully Tyrell
will make contact or will get something
else that'll change the pace there
really soon so I'm not buying into the
idea that there will be another major
Elliot delusion plot twist this season
like the one we got in the first season
when mr. robot like many of the popular
theories have been speculating but there
are a couple things here that are
noticeably not sitting right so all of
this has me really excited for the next
episode and I'm also really excited to
know what you guys think - so let me
know in the comment it was Tyrell on the
phone and he was basically right outside
Joe in his apartment right what was the
point of the gunmen coming in to shoot
up the FBI in China can Elliot get out
from under the situation with Rae on
and how far is he going to have to go to
make sure he can get away
well price figure out what Angela is up
to with eff society and what are those
guys doing with the drone in DC also
where the hell is madame executioner I
mean they brought her out like a new
character in the very first episode and
we have not seen her anywhere and it's
starting to get a little bit odd that
Angela or Darlene can just squat in the
apartment indefinitely so please like
this video if you found that enjoyable
and you want to see more mr. robot
videos in the future and subscribe to my
channel to get the new stuff as soon as
it comes out make sure to check out my
other mr. robot episode reviews thanks
for watching I will talk to you soon